The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at OCW.MIT.edu.
PROFESSOR: I'm excited, because
I'm going to get the chance
to co-teach today with--
I would say one of the
students, but it's not really
one of the students.
But Larry Lessig has consented
to join us in a few minutes.
So I'm going to be
breezing through
a little faster than usual.
And then we'll co-teach this.
Blockchain and Money.
Here we are.
We're at smart contracts.
Everybody seems
to be coming back,
which is a sign of your interest
more than it is in my teaching.
But I thank you for being here.
We made it through
the last three classes
together on bitcoin and the
basics of that technology.
And in one class,
we're going to try
to chew off a bit
on smart contracts,
both the technology side, a
little bit on the markets,
and then the law that Larry
is going to take us through.
And so as I said,
I want to start
with a little
administrative, because we
are on the sixth class.
I'm going to review a bit about
the projects very quickly.
We're going to do smart
contracts, the design.
What design features?
Yes, we're going to
go back a little bit
about hash functions and
Merkle trees but not too much.
DApps, which are basically
decentralized applications,
and token sales.
Larry's going to take
us through legal issues,
and then we'll sum it all up.
So let me just, real fast on
the administrative side again--
class participation, 30%.
That's why we're
all here together.
That means, hopefully,
reading the assignments
and participating.
About half of you
have participated,
so I guess I'm going to
go with a little bit more
cold calling starting Thursday.
I'm not going to do a bunch
of it today, because Larry
and I are joining.
So you can ease off.
But really be conscious.
If you haven't been
participating, try to get in
and join the conversation
and discussion.
The two individual write-ups,
I think we have seven.
But it's quite possible some
of you have submitted already.
It's just meant to be
critical business reasoning.
We are in a business school.
To the extent you just
summarize some readings,
I'm sure we'll give
you a pass on that.
But that's not what
I'm looking for.
I'm really looking
for critical reasoning
and thinking from a
business perspective
of, why does this matter?
What are its strengths
or its values
in terms of business reasoning
and critical reasoning?
One by the 10th class, one by
the 23rd, always before class.
What it likely means
is we'll be getting
most of these on the
8th, 9th, and 10th class.
I know how that
works and so forth.
And that's OK.
That's OK.
But I'm just
reminding you of that.
In terms of the
group research paper,
again, Sabrina and Thalita
stood up a Google App--
I think it's in Google, but--
where you can go in and team
up in teams of three or four.
It's not required to do this by
the eighth class next Tuesday,
but I'm strongly
suggesting it to figure out
who your teams are and not sort
of wait till the second half
of the semester.
And I'd like to
encourage everybody
to choose an area for
your use case by midway.
Again, you're not
going to get graded
if it takes you another class
or two to figure it out.
But I just think it's much
better if you know your teams,
you know what your
use case will be.
If it's not about finance--
one group has already asked
me if that's all right.
I just want to know more
detailed what it's going to be.
I'm probably going
to say yes, but it
needs a little
bit of preapproval
if it's outside of finance.
So any questions about
the requirements?
I just wanted to--
So the study questions.
Today's smart contracts
and basically how they
compare to regular contracts.
And what are the tokens that
are used within that ecosystem?
And what are the platforms?
In a very similar sense to the
internet, we have the internet.
And then above the internet,
you have, you might say,
applications--
Facebook and other applications.
Well, this, too, has
a series of platforms
and then decentralized
applications
potentially on top of that.
And basically, a quick touch
on decentralized applications.
Later in the
semester, we're going
to take two sessions on
initial coin offerings.
And thus, we're going to talk
a lot about token economics.
So this will be just
the first taste test,
and then we'll come
back to it later.
And then the readings,
hopefully, everybody
read through "Smart Contracts."
I thought the Chamber
of Digital Commerce,
even though this is
almost two years ago,
this paper was a very
helpful sort of flavor
for what folks in
commerce are thinking
and what developers
were thinking.
And I love that Nick Szabo
wrote the introduction to it.
And it's interesting
to see and question,
why is it that it's
two years later,
and many of those use cases
are still being discussed
but haven't fully been adopted?
And then the "State
of the Dapps,"
and then who are the
competitors to Ethereum?
So don't you feel good?
I haven't asked anybody
a cold question yet.
And then the optional
readings, I don't know.
Did anybody actually go back?
They're optional.
Did anybody go back and read
either Szabo's original piece
from 20 years ago
on smart contracts?
Oh, a few of you are kind
of into that rabbit hole
of blockchain and ether.
Brotish what did you think of--
it's 20 years ago he wrote this
thing on--
Nick Szabo wrote this thing.
AUDIENCE: Actually,
I spent more time
on the Ethereum white paper.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So what did you think about
the Ethereum white paper one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think
it was pretty good.
It gave me a very good
overview of the world potential
of the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
And what's interesting is
even if you didn't do it
for the class and you find
yourself more and more
interested in this over the next
couple of months or even later,
going back and reading
the Ethereum white paper,
it's not highly technical
in the first, I don't know,
10 or 15 pages.
It really gives a
history of bitcoin.
It talks about
distributed applications
and largely written at the
time by a 19-year-old, as well.
It's a remarkable thing.
And then one of Larry's
colleague, or maybe it's
two of them, but De
Philippi paper, as well,
on the regulatory issues.
So let me talk a little
bit about smart contracts
and laying groundwork before
Larry gives us the law.
A smart contract is
a set of promises
specified in a digital form.
I'm going to say four things.
It's just a set of
promises in a digital form.
So it's not handwritten out.
It includes protocols.
What's a protocol?
Andrew.
AUDIENCE: Standard
operating procedure.
PROFESSOR: Standard
I like that.
Anybody else give me
another word for it, maybe?
An algorithm.
So a set of promises
in digital form.
But it can include math,
basically, if you wish
or standard operating
procedures-- if-then statements
and so forth.
And the parties then perform
against these promises.
And guess what?
Nick Szabo wrote that in 1996.
And I thought it was
still probably the best
definition of smart contract.
He coined the
phrase 22 years ago.
He might actually
be Satoshi Nakamoto.
Three of the tables
in here, you all
voted that it was Nick Szabo.
So I thought that's kind
of the best definition
if you've got to
just-- kind of a root.
Now, I would also say, however,
that smart contracts may not
be so smart.
A lot of people have
come to be calling them
dumb contracts that
are just algorithms
that perform a function.
So don't think of them as
artificial intelligence.
That's another class provided
next semester by Simon Johnson.
Think of them almost
as just dumb contracts.
And in a sense,
they're mechanizing
what might otherwise be done
amongst and between humans.
And smart contracts may or
may not be really contracts.
And that's why Larry's
going to speak to it.
So remember, even though Nick
Szabo calls it smart contracts,
they may not be smart, and
they may not be contracts.
So a little bit about
the technical features.
Remember our three
ways we did this.
What are the big technical
features that we studied?
I'm sorry to do this.
Anton, what are the
three big buckets?
Remember, we took three
classes and three buckets
of information.
It can be one to three.
AUDIENCE: Cryptography.
PROFESSOR: Cryptography.
Great.
You got one.
Two other people will
give me the others.
So cryptography.
Guess what?
Bitcoin and Ethereum all
have the same cryptography.
It's not identical.
But for the purposes
of design features,
it has cryptographic hashes,
timestamps, block headers,
Merkle trees.
Though Ethereum has more than
one Merkle tree, and bitcoin
has one.
And it has digital
signatures and addresses.
So everything we
talked about three
lectures ago about cryptography,
both forms of blockchains.
Anybody want to give me
what our second bucket was?
Geramo.
AUDIENCE: Decentralization.
PROFESSOR: Decentralization.
What else did we talk about?
Eilon.
AUDIENCE: Consensus.
PROFESSOR: Consensus.
So again, decentralized
network consensus.
Ethereum actually
uses proof of work
even there's some
talk that Ether
will move to proof of stake.
But it's currently
proof of work.
There is a native currency.
It's ETH, or "eh-th," or E-T-H,
or Ether, instead of bitcoin.
And it has a network.
The third thing that
we talked about, Alpha.
AUDIENCE: Transaction format.
PROFESSOR: Transaction format.
So we talked about
transactions and script.
Well, guess what?
Ethereum does not have a
transaction script or UTXO.
So that's the one place
that Vatalik Buterin, who
designed all of this, said
no, had to go a different way.
Instead of transaction
inputs and outputs,
there's something called
state transitions.
Isabella, ledgers.
What are the two
different types of ledgers
that we talked about
and set a class to?
AUDIENCE: Permissioned
and public.
PROFESSOR: So
permissioned and public
are two different
types of blockchains.
Remind me your name again.
Stephanie.
AUDIENCE: Balance ledgers
and transaction ledgers.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So balance ledger and
transaction ledger.
You can keep a list
of transactions.
And this goes back
thousands of years.
This is not a blockchain.
Or you can keep balances.
Bitcoin is, in essence,
a transaction ledger.
Ethereum and many of
the other smart contract
platforms are balance ledgers.
There's a lot of technological
and mathematical reasons why,
which I'd be glad to
do in office hours.
But because of that,
when you're moving
from one set of balances, like--
is it Bo?
Bo has $100 at Bank of
America to Bo having $101.
You need to have a transition.
It's called a state transition,
which would mean add $1.
So Ethereum is account based
and, in fact, doesn't even
have one programming language.
There's six or seven
programming languages
you can write in, for
those who are so inclined.
So I'm going to go through
really quickly my analysis,
and many other
people's, but my sort
of rendition of the difference
between Ethereum and bitcoin.
But stop me if
there's a question.
So the founder.
There's actually a founder.
The mythology around
Vatalik Buterin
might not be as great
as Satoshi Nakamoto.
But a 19-year-old journalist who
was writing about bitcoin for--
was it Bitcoin Magazine, if I
remember where he was writing--
said, we can build
something on top
of it using Nick Szabo's
thoughts about smart contracts,
about six years after bitcoin.
He made it Turing complete.
Does anyone want to remind the
class what Turing complete is?
Did I see a hand up?
Yes.
Bold of you.
What's your first name again?
AUDIENCE: Alana.
PROFESSOR: Alana.
AUDIENCE: You could write
pretty much any-- well,
you can write loops, but you
write any kind of program,
like any form of
logic is expressed.
PROFESSOR: So Alana
says Turing complete
means you can write loops.
But what that really means
for the business crowd is it
means you can write a program
to do just about anything.
It's highly flexible.
I'm sure the technologist in
here will say, well, maybe
there's something
you can't do with it.
But the point in
what Vatalik said
is we shouldn't just limit it
to a scripting language that
was non-Turing
complete that can just
move a little bit of
peer-to-peer value around,
that he wanted to do basically
a peer-to-peer virtual computer
that could move code
and complete code.
And over the years,
it's being able to be
written in a bunch of things.
But Solidity is the
main program language.
And thus, it's account based
rather than transaction
based because of the loops.
If you could loop and be Turing
complete with transactions,
there is a vulnerability
in attack factors
that he made it account based.
The transactions are
stored in Merkle keys.
But guess what?
If you were really interested
and wanted to learn everything
about Ethereum, there's at
least four key Merkle trees
that get summarized up
into the block headers.
There's the transactions,
which, in essence,
aren't transactions.
They call them
state transitions.
There's the state
itself, something
called storage, which is
really related to each one
of the individual Ethereum
accounts, and then,
believe it or not,
actually, receipts.
There's written records of
receipts from every state
transition.
So there's a lot more complexity
inside the Ethereum blockchain.
They run about 14 seconds a
block instead of 10 minutes.
And that change is a
bunch of the economics.
Proof of work, for some
reason, which others can study.
Vatalik decided to use a
different hash function.
It's still based on
elliptic curves, I think,
but a different hash function.
What about the economics?
Well, it's called ETH or E-T-H.
It's programmed in such a way
that you can't use
ASICs, purposely
makes it that mining
is more decentralized,
and you don't have
the big factories.
The entire hash community,
the entire mining community,
is much smaller.
In fact, I think it's about--
what would that be?
200,000 times smaller.
There's 260 terahashes per
second as of yesterday.
And the bitcoin mining
community has 54 exahashes.
That means lots more computers,
a lot more electricity,
a lot more gnashing of
teeth about resources.
Bitcoin started in
January of 2009.
And nobody owned any bitcoin,
whereas Ethereum started
with a presale and an ICO,
which we'll be talking about,
about 72 million Ethereum.
Vatalik wanted to raise money
he was maybe 19 years old.
He looped in with a
venture capitalist
from Canada, Joe Lubin,
who now runs ConsenSys.
Lubin took about 10% or 9
and 1/2% of the offering.
They put 9 and 1/2%
in a foundation
called the Ethereum Foundation.
And the other 80% was sold to
the public for $18 million.
We'll talk later
in the semester as
to whether that was really
a securities offering.
I've publicly said I think
so, but that was in 2014.
And in 2018, the Securities
and Exchange Commission
has said regardless of why
it might have been in '14,
it's now sufficiently
decentralized
that we'll consider
it not a security.
But in essence, they
raised $18 million
and were off to the races.
Oh, and the 10% that Joe Lubin
kept, if he still owned it,
would be worth about
$2 billion now.
But he probably sold
some of it along the way.
There are block rewards.
The monetary policy in
Ethereum, if you remember,
it splits every four years.
There's the block reward splits.
Ethereum was set up that it
was five Ether per block.
And then a year ago,
they just announced
they were going to
change the software
to three Ether per block.
And a month ago, they
announced they're
going to change it to
two Ether per block.
So the monetary policy of
bitcoin is said to be immutable
and fixed forever.
But I would say that because
Ethereum supposedly was fixed
and now, twice, they've
changed the monetary policy,
there is a form that if all
the miners and all the computer
nodes decide, they can
change the monetary policy.
And Ethereum has shown that.
I think Ethereum's a
bit more centralized
and has more leadership,
because Vatalik Buterin
is an actual human who is
willing to disclose who he is.
And he still has the sort
of founder following.
And Satoshi Nakamoto went--
he ghosted all of
us, in a sense.
And so thus, it's in some
ways socially just more
decentralized.
And then fees are
voluntary in bitcoin.
They're a necessary part
to channel everything.
Emily.
AUDIENCE: Going back
to monetary policy,
in practice, what
does it actually mean
for a difference between bitcoin
and Ethereum that it's fixed
but changing versus
staying at the same rate?
PROFESSOR: So Emily asks,
what does it mean in practice?
In practice, bitcoin has a much
slower growth rate or inflation
rate, which is currently, if
I'm not mistaken, about half.
What's that?
About 4%.
But it's about half of the
inflation rate at Ethereum,
which is running
in the 7% range.
Every one of the
1,600 live tokens
that are right
now Ott coins have
separate monetary policies.
And one could do a
complete economic study
about what it means.
But in terms of
Ethereum versus bitcoin,
Ethereum has a higher
inflation rate.
And secondly,
because they've shown
that they can form some
consensus and change it,
I think it sends an
interesting question
into that ecosystem as to how
hard a monetary policy versus
a more human-based,
flexible monetary policy.
Hugo.
AUDIENCE: So is it that the
core developers of the Ethereum
blockchain decide?
I'm not familiar with how they
make that decision to change
the monetary policy.
PROFESSOR: So the core
developers of any coin
can propose to the
various mining and nodes
to make a change, including
the monetary policy.
Even in bitcoin,
the monetary policy
could change if
there was a proposal
from the core developers.
In the Ethereum case,
they have done that twice.
The core development
of Ethereum is
highly concentrated around
the Ethereum Foundation.
ConsenSys, the company
that Joe Lubin runs,
has some normative social
standing in the community,
as well.
But it's been part of proposals.
And in reading the proposals, it
goes back to Emily's question.
The core developers have said we
should bring down the inflation
rate.
There's an active advocacy to
bring down the inflation rate.
AUDIENCE: So you go by
updating your node software?
PROFESSOR: Yes, in essence.
And it could lead to a
hard fork, I believe.
So that's the background.
Let me just talk
about the platforms.
We know about Ethereum.
We've just chatted about it.
Its actual current market
value is $22 billion.
While we're not going to spend
a lot of time in this class
this semester about
market values,
I thought it would
give you a sense
of how people think about it.
The other five that you
did some reading about.
EOS, whose market value
is about $5 billion,
is so new, because they just
finished an initial coin
offering in July.
And they just went live in July.
But they raised $4.2 billion.
So my estimate, my prediction,
is EOS is going to be real
and going to be around.
They've taken $1 billion
of that $4.2 billion
and set up a Kickstarter
sort of venture firm
literally so that they could
maybe support some of you.
You could be knocking on
the EOS venture firm's door
and saying fund me.
I've got a great idea.
And they'd have one
condition, amongst others.
You'd have to use
EOS as the platform.
So it's a self-reinforcing
business model.
NEO is the other big
one that I'd mention,
which was started two years ago
out of China, a lot of people
think with the backing of
the Chinese government.
Even if not officially,
certainly with the verbal
and help of there.
Some people think of it
as the Ethereum of China,
but it does use a
different proof of work.
And those are the main ones.
Ethereum Classic is
there because there
was a hard fork off of Ethereum
after the DAO circumstance.
Any quick questions
about the platforms?
And NEO and EOS
are thought to be
a little bit higher
throughput and faster because
of the different proof of
work that each of them have.
So maybe they're more scalable
than Ethereum long term.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What's that?
PROFESSOR: So Hugo is pointing
out that neither one truly
use--
NEO and EOS truly use
decentralized proof of work.
They use a delegated
Byzantine fault tolerance.
This was from the reading.
We're not going to
spend time on it.
But there was 12 use cases that
the Digital Chamber of Commerce
came up with.
And we're going to study
most of these, not all
of these, later in the semester.
Please tell me, Sean.
AUDIENCE: So from the
growth perspective
across different
platforms, do you
support multi programming
language platforms as opposed
to single-language
programming platforms?
Which one do you think
has more potential?
PROFESSOR: The question is,
do multi-language platforms
have more potential or less
than single-language platforms?
I haven't done a real study.
My gut tells me that
there's some trade-offs.
So a multi-language
platform probably
allows for more
development of apps,
just like on the
internet, if you
can have more app development.
Though if you have only
one single language,
you might have fewer
vulnerabilities,
vulnerabilities either
to attack or coming down.
So there's probably
some trade-offs.
And I'm more into
democratizing capital markets,
so probably my biases
would be to the ones that
have multi-language potential.
But I can't say for sure
whether it will necessarily
win, because there are some
trade-offs, if that helps.
So we'll take a view of all of
these later in the semester.
But what's interesting is none
of them have yet taken off.
And in fact, if you
look at the dApps today,
the decentralized
applications which
run on a decentralized
blockchain,
they generally
have native tokens.
They don't have to have a
native token, by the way.
You can run a dApp
based on Ether.
You could run a dApp
on an underlying token.
But they almost always have
their own native token.
This is a list that I pulled
off the internet yesterday
similar to your reading.
These are the actual dApps
that are working the highest--
gaming, gambling,
exchanges, and finance.
The most active dApp
is a gambling site that
only has 1,500 users a day.
In the last 24 hours--
I pulled this down yesterday,
so that was a Monday.
So this would have been
Sunday night to Monday night.
There was only 1,500 users to
the most active gambling site.
CryptoKitties that
some of you might know
had 418 users in those 24 hours.
These are not economy
wise use cases.
You would see numbers that
were hundreds of thousands.
Or if it's like Facebook,
there's two billion members.
And probably in any 24 hours,
there's a half a billion
to a billion people that
check in on Facebook.
So these are pretty
limited at this stage.
But it has led to something
called initial coin
offerings, which
we're going to study
a bunch later in the semester.
Initial coin offerings raise
money to build a network.
But the tokens are usually
issued before they're usable.
And a token is some
native currency
to be used on a network.
The development is open
but highly centralized.
The promoters usually
give themselves some skin
in the game or some vig.
In the Ethereum
initial coin offering,
the Foundation kept 10%.
Joe Lubin kept 10%.
And the other 80% was
sold to the public.
But some keep 60% or
80% for themselves.
I mean, it's a whole wide
range of economic incentives
and models.
And the tokens are usually
fungible and transferable.
And thus, you can sort
put them on an exchange
and try to sell them
and promote them.
And again, we're
going to come back.
But I thought if we're
talking about smart contracts,
they tie into initial
coin offerings.
Daniel.
AUDIENCE: If the tokens
aren't functional,
what goes into their evaluation?
PROFESSOR: That is an
excellent question.
Daniel says, what goes into
the valuation of something
that is not functional?
And there are many
things that go in.
Ultimately, it's
in the anticipation
of the potential profit and
appreciation in the future.
So if you were just
to have a laundromat,
a corner laundromat
here in Cambridge,
you probably would only pay
for the laundromat token what
you thought the value was to do
your laundry, $0.75 or whatever
the--
frankly, I don't know what the
tokens go for in Cambridge.
You're going to tell me what
a laundromat token goes for?
But if it's prefunctional
and the laundromat has not
been built yet and you have
confidence it will be built,
you'll probably discount back.
You might pay $0.50 instead
of the $0.75, ultimately.
If you think it's going to be
a really popular laundromat
and it's going to be the place
to be seen by all MIT students
and you think that token
might one day be worth $5,
then you're starting
to speculate
on the community's interest.
So these tokens, if you
really believe in them,
you're trying to pay
for what others will
pay for them in the future.
And the economic equilibrium
would be discounted.
So thus, you're buying
it because you think
they'll appreciate in value.
AUDIENCE: Couldn't you
make an argument sort
of following
numismatics, how people
assign some aesthetic
value to physical coins?
So, too, you could
have an impulse
beyond speculation [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Your first name is?
AUDIENCE: Isaac.
PROFESSOR: Isaac.
Isaac says maybe there could
be a numismatic or other value
to it.
It's possible.
I mean, certainly,
CryptoKitties caught
into the whole
collectibles wave.
Let me try to wrap up so that
I can hand it off to Larry.
So there's been
$28 billion raised
per one website, Elementis.
Others that track
it think it's only
between $20 and $25 billion.
There are no official arithmetic
and no official records.
But the $28 billion raised
in initial coin offerings,
this is a cut of a
neat video that I just
took the last slide
of from Elementis.
You can watch it in
a minute and a half.
And over the years,
it's geographically
dispersed with blue
being Oceana, Australia,
and so forth, green being Asia,
North America being orange.
But the biggest ones,
EOS raised $4.2 billion.
Telegram, $1.7
billion and the like.
These are not small figures.
There's been at least
4,500 proposed initial coin
offerings.
Many of them didn't raise any
money, but over 2,000 to 3,000
have raised money.
I'm going to use
the 3,000 figure.
Less than half of them
are even live today.
There's one study that
shows that 59% fail
within the first nine months.
There are other studies that say
between 1/4 and 3/4 are scams.
Christian Catalina
here has a study
which I think is probably
the most valid and reliable,
which says 25% are
scams or frauds.
Statis has one that
says 80% might be.
AUDIENCE: You said 59% fail.
Can you talk more about
what "failure" means here?
Does that mean it just
goes to 0 or there's
a technological deficiency?
PROFESSOR: Can I
hold that until later
when we're going to dig
into these in the class?
But broad definition of fail,
so it's not just technology.
It means that you can't even
find the website anymore.
They took your
money, and they ran.
Or they still have a
website, but it's not live.
It doesn't seem like there's
a development team any longer.
So multiple
definitions of failure.
So that brings us
to legal issues.
And as Larry brings
up his computer,
let me just introduce our guest
lecturer, Larry Lessig, who's
an esteemed Harvard
professor of law.
He was at Stanford.
He started something
called the Center
for Internet and Society.
You clerked for
Justice Scalia, so you
must have some real views on
what's going on this week,
then.
And this incredible appellate
court judge, Posner.
And Larry also-- his first of--
whatever you're up
to, 9 or 10 books now?
LARRY LESSIG: It's something.
I don't know.
PROFESSOR: But his first
was code and the law
that I referenced in
our first lecture.
Larry is going to take it away.
LARRY LESSIG: OK, great.
So I'm really happy
to be able to say
that I've taught business
school students at MIT.
I mean, I'm a tech wannabe.
But I have never been allowed
to be officially here,
so this is exciting.
But what I want to
do is really address
what I've experienced
as misperceptions
about the nature
of the law as it
might interact with the issues
around digital contracts.
So I teach contracts.
Contract law is one of the
subjects which I've taught
since I started teaching.
And so I want to frame
four points for you
about how to think
about contract law
as it relates to these
potential digital contracts.
But the first
thing to do is just
to make sure we
understand we're all
talking about the same thing.
OK.
So here's what the
core of contract law
teaches us contracts are.
Contract is a promise
or performance
given in exchange for a
promise or performance.
"Given in exchange for"
is really critical.
That's the quid pro
quo that's sometimes
referred to as the
consideration for the promise.
But notice here,
this is mapping out
four different possibilities.
You can have a promise in
exchange for a promise.
I promise to pay you $10,000
if you promise to sing
an opera for me tomorrow.
Or it can be a promise
for a performance.
I promise to pay you, Andy, $5
if you sing a song for us now.
So it's the performance I want.
I don't want a promise
from him, because we know
what Andy's promises are worth.
Or it could be a
performance for a promise.
I'll sing if you promise
to pay me after I'm done.
Or the really interesting
one for our purposes
is a performance
for a performance.
I'll sing if you pay me $5,000.
I didn't want a promise from
you, because I don't trust you.
You're business school students.
So I just want the money.
But I'm not promising
to do anything.
I'm actually going to
do something for you.
Now, that's the one
that we're going
to think about in the
context of digital contracts.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Let me just fix one thing here.
Actually, I was going
to make three points,
but then I decided I
was going to make four.
So let me fix that.
Four points about contracts.
So the first point
about contracts,
so think about this case.
All right.
It's not quite digital, but
it's a physical contract
machine in the sense that it's
a performance for a performance.
If you drop a dime
into this machine,
then out will come Dr.
Pepper or something else.
OK.
So there's no promises involved.
And we understand there's
a mechanism that's
to produce this result.
And obviously, these
have been here for a long time.
And these mechanisms
provide real value,
because to the extent you
don't have to hire somebody
to stand there handing
out Dr. Peppers,
you can lower the cost
of delivering Dr. Peppers
and increase the
market for Dr. Pepper.
So this is the
motivation-- lower
the transaction
costs of engaging
in a particular kind
of contract, which
is performance for performance.
Now, when you look
at that contract,
you should ask yourself, what
are the terms of this contract?
All right.
So some of them are express,
and they're pretty obvious.
So this says $0.10.
It says if you pay $0.10,
you will get the Dr. Pepper.
Or that's what you
kind of expect.
There's a great cartoon I
couldn't find where you come
to a machine that
says deposit $0.50.
Deposits $0.50, and
the light comes on.
It says, thank you very much.
Right.
So you think you know
what this contract is,
but that joke hints
that maybe you don't
know what that contract is.
But the express terms
of the one we expect
go with a statement,
the machine.
But then there's a whole
bunch of implied terms.
So one implied term if this
machine is in the United States
is that when you take the Dr.
Pepper out and you drink it,
it's actually going
to be safe to drink.
It's actually going
to be Dr. Pepper.
It's actually not
going to make you sick.
And none of that is written
on the Dr. Pepper machine.
That's instead a
term, a contract term,
that gets created by the law
and gets imposed or wrapped
around the delivery
of that drink.
OK.
That's their first point.
The second point
is to think more
about what these
implied terms imply.
Because if these implied terms
are implied by a legal system,
then that means the
legal system has
an interest in your contract.
Legal system is
not undisinterested
in your contract.
So we should always
think that our contract
is going to have two parties.
We call them the promisor
and the promisee.
I've told you
we've had contracts
that can be performance.
"The performancer"
isn't really a word.
But let's just say
promisor and promisee.
But there's always
a third party,
which is the state, who is
in the middle of the contract
in the sense that the state
will police many contracts
and decide whether the state
likes the contract or not.
And if the state doesn't
like the contract,
then the state won't
enforce the contract.
Or the state might
actually punish you
because of the contract.
So for example, the state cares
about the kinds of contracts.
You can have contracts
for the sale of tables.
You can't have contracts
for the sale of people.
But you can sell dogs for
reasons I can't understand.
But the point is we are
deciding which type of things
can be sold and which kind
of things can't be sold.
The state cares about the
effect of the contract.
If the contract is to
render your corporation
vulnerable to
bankruptcy, the state
might have an
interest in deciding
whether that contract
will be enforced
or not or whether it'll
be allowed or not,
whether it's permissible
under bankruptcy laws
to engage in that contract
because of the risk
that it's going to create.
The state's going to care about
the terms of the contract.
So if you're selling your labor
in a state with a minimum wage
law, the state's going to care.
Does the term that
specifies your wage equal
or exceed the minimum wage?
And states can obviously
care-- the most important thing
for the state is whether
and how the state
taxes the transaction
in the contract.
So when does it tax
the transaction?
What is the event that's
going to manifest it?
And of course, the
contract can try
to play with that sort of deal
with whether it will be taxed.
And the state will care about
how the contract deals with it.
OK.
So the point is to fight
against the first real bias
that especially,
let's say, tech people
and maybe business
tech people bring
to the idea of contract law,
which is that contracts are not
about the state.
They're about private parties.
That's not true.
They're about private
parties and the state.
And the state is always
going to be there.
Now, so if I say
to you, I'm trying
to sell my parents' house.
I can't sell it.
So if I say to
you, I'll offer you
$10,000 to anyone who will
burn down my parents' house.
You're trying to
accept that contract.
You're raising your hand,
so you're trying to accept.
I want to say officially
it's a joke so nobody gets
any uncertainty about this.
Now, you're going to ask
a question, because I
didn't want you to accept.
Because if you accepted
my offer, then that's it.
I'm stuck.
So now it's clear it's
not really an offer,
and I can ask you a question.
AUDIENCE: So you said contracts
cannot be between two parties.
They have to be between
two parties and the state.
LARRY LESSIG: No.
So let me say it more clearly.
Contracts always have
the state present,
so it's always
between two parties
or three parties or four.
So you and I enter
into a contract.
Not this one, but another one.
But the state is in
the room and deciding
whether the state's going to
allow the contract to happen.
So most contracts, the
state doesn't care about.
But some contracts, the
state's going to say,
hell no, we're not going
to allow it, like this one.
If you didn't get that
notice it was a joke
and you thought I was
serious and you went and you
burned down my parents' house so
that we could get the insurance
and not have to worry
about selling the house,
and then you came to me, and
you said, OK, pay the $10,000.
And I said, it was
an obvious joke.
And you went to a court,
and you said, force Lessig
to pay the $10,000.
The court will say this
is an illegal contract.
I'm not going to
enforce this contract.
So my point is the state,
in a certain sense,
is the censor of this contract.
The state is in the room
when we make this contract.
And the state's
judgment about it
will decide whether
we enforce it or not.
Is that clearer?
AUDIENCE: So you're not saying
the state has to be there.
LARRY LESSIG: I'm not saying
the state is technically
signing the document.
But I'm getting you
to recognize the fact
that the contract is valuable
to the extent it's enforceable.
And the state is the
essential agent in enforcement
in the real world.
AUDIENCE: So I guess that's
my question, because it seems
like nowadays, we can have
contracts where the enforcement
is not the state.
I can put a contract
out there that says,
hey, if you can
factor this number,
give me the prime factors of
it, I'll give you 10 Ether.
LARRY LESSIG: Yeah.
And what I started with
when I was showing you
this picture was to
say, actually, that's
been true for a while, right?
So in what sense
is the state here?
Well, the state is here if
when you put the dime in
and you get the drink out and
the drink doesn't have Dr.
Pepper but it has
gasoline in it,
the state would come
in and say, whoa, wait.
You've breached the
implied term that said
that this was safe to consume.
So the state is in
this contract, too.
And so what I'm trying to
lead to or get to the place
where we say, is there ever a
place where the state is not
there, which is what I think
your blockchain-like invocation
is.
So that's a question we're
going to get to in a second.
Here's another contract.
We'll offer you $50,000 to
lobby Congress to pass HR102.
This contract looks
pretty normal to us.
You can imagine lobbyists
have a contract like this
all the time.
In fact, in the middle
of the 19th century,
the Supreme Court
ruled this contract
was an illegal contract.
You weren't allowed to hire
people to lobby Congress,
right?
So again, the
background norm of what
is appropriate or not for the
contract controlled what type
of contracting was allowed.
OK.
So that's about the
type of contract.
But then think about the
terms of the contract.
And so now, I want to
get you to recognize
the way in which the terms
that the law wants a contract
to have can be defeated
or not by technology.
And the way I'm going to
get you to think about that
is to think about not contract
law but something that
will create the intuitions
I want you to have.
Think about copyright law.
Everybody knows
copyright law, right?
I hope you know something
about copyright law.
So copyright law is a basic
contract with the state.
But the state says, if
you create something,
then you're going to get
an exclusive right to it
or exclusive rights,
a set of rights--
an inclusive right to copy,
an exclusive right to sell it,
exclusive right to make
derivative works of it--
for a period of time--
and in America right now,
that's your life plus 70 years--
subject to fair
use, meaning the law
says you can't control every
use of my copyrighted work.
If you want to take a book
of mine and quote a section
and write a review that says,
see how idiotic Lessig is?
You can do that.
And I can't wrap the
book in a contract that
says you're not allowed to quote
it for purposes of criticizing.
I'm just not allowed to do that.
So copyright law, imagine
this bundle of rights
that it was offering.
But now imagine something called
DRM, Digital Rights Management.
All right.
So DRM is a set of code that we
can wrap copyrighted material
in in the process of making
it available to others
across networks
and whatever else.
It's pretty trivial
to see the way
DRM could, in effect, destroy
the limitations on the term.
You can wrap it,
encrypt it, make it
so that my ability to
control it will be my ability
to control it, conceivably, as
long as machines are running.
If it's a
Microsoft-based system,
four years later, it
won't be workable.
But the point is, in
principle, it could be forever.
Same thing with fair use.
You can imagine it being
wrapped in a way that
disables the capacity
to engage in fair use.
So I make tons of
presentations all the time
where I need to capture video.
And I was astonished
to discover the latest
round of this operating
system basically
makes it incredibly
difficult to rip
video for the purpose
of capturing even two
seconds of it.
So if you have a video program
that is capturing your screen,
this operating system
will now disable it
for any period of
time that you're
trying to capture the screen.
They've built the technology
so that, now, there
is no capacity,
technical capacity,
to engage in fair
use of copyrighted
material on the Apple platform.
Now, you might say,
why should they
be allowed to do that
if the law intended
that the contract gives you
the free use of fair use?
Why should they be
allowed to do that?
But that's the battle that's
been going on about DRM
ever since the beginning of
the beginning of copyrighted
work on the internet.
So my point is to
get you to realize
the way the code becomes part
of the law of this contract.
And you have to ask
yourself the question
whether that law is respecting
the law of the sovereign,
the law of the jurisdiction.
So when Apple and
Disney get together
and they sell this
technology and they
sell movies across
the iTunes platform
that make it
practically impossible--
there's not even code.
I mean, if you go out
there and you look,
you can find everybody who
says, yeah, with this version,
nobody's yet found
a way to break it.
So right now, we're in a
world where, right now, it's
not possible for me to
capture three seconds to put
into a presentation.
And the issue that
raises is, to what extent
is that consistent
with copyright law
if the technology
now disables you
from doing exactly what
copyright law wants?
So this is the trade-off
to think about,
the relationship between the
policy that the law wants
and the policy of
the technology.
And there's no reason to believe
the policy of the technology
will always be
consistent with the law.
And to the extent it's not
consistent with the law,
it challenges the law.
It says to the law, OK,
come out and get me.
Now, that obviously
is implicated
in the context of
smart contracts,
because the biggest fear
about smart contracts
is that they enable a kind
of transaction that can hide
from the policy of the law.
So the question for the law is,
what will you do to step in?
And this is, I think, where
your question was going.
How does the state appear in
the middle of that contract?
But let's take one more
step before we get to that.
OK.
That's the second point.
Here's the third point.
There's often this intuition
that, especially technologists,
people have about what the
particular aim of contract law
is.
So in the very
beginning of me writing
about the law of cyberspace,
somebody from MIT--
I won't name any
names-- it wasn't Andy--
showed up at the Harvard
Law School and said,
I've solved the problem
of contract law.
I said, what do you mean?
He said, I have a system
that will eliminate risks
in contracts.
And he was really disappointed
when I said, you know,
the objective of contract law
is not to eliminate risks.
The objective of contract
law is just to allocate risk,
to figure out who has
the risk, so each of us
can figure out what to
do in light of the risk.
So if I say I will buy
10,000 bushels of corn
from you at $350 a bushel--
turns out that is the
price of corn right now.
He always looks up
things on the internet.
I figure I should look it
up before I present it.
So $350 is the price of a bushel
of corn right now delivered
September 1.
What that's basically
doing is it's allocating
the risk of the price of corn.
So if you're a
farmer and you don't
want to face the risk the price
of corn is going to fall to $3,
you enter into this contract.
If you're a buyer, you
accept this contract.
But if the price of
corn falls to $3,
well, you're out of luck.
So the point is it
relocates the price change,
reallocates the risk
of price change,
also reallocates the
risk of delivery.
So if I've got all this corn, I
can place it in a certain place
to shift the risk of delivery
so that, once again, I
use the contract to
shift my risk of storage
or my risk of delivery
and you on the other side.
So the objective of
contract law, number one,
is risk allocation.
Number one.
But allocation matters only if--
trying to say only if for me--
only if there is a
system to process
the breach of a contract, only
if you've got a technology,
let's say, for
processing the breach.
So if I have a
contract with you--
10,000 bushels of corn,
$3.50, on September 1--
and you don't deliver,
that's a breach.
My risk has only
been reallocated
if there's some way
for me to enforce
the contract at that point.
So it requires the system.
And the system we
ordinarily take for granted
is a legal system.
And I say we take
it for granted,
meaning some people can
take it for granted,
like people in well-developed
legal contexts.
But that's also to emphasized
other people can't take it
for granted--
so for example, people
in developing worlds.
They can't take the
legal system for granted.
They can't assume that if
the contract is breached,
they go into a court and
say, enforce the contract
or give me damages.
Or if you've got a
contract between somebody
in Rwanda and
somebody in Alaska,
then there, too,
there's a question
of whether we've got sufficient
infrastructure to develop.
So the point I want to
emphasize at the end
of this little
intervention is to suggest
that this fact that it
takes for granted the system
of enforcement shows the real
potential benefit of this class
of contracting devices.
Because if we think about
this as a representation
of a well-developed
legal system and we
think of first-world
countries as having those
and we compare third-world
or developing world
countries, which don't have
these well-developed legal
systems, you might say that
first-world countries are
better off relative to
third-world countries,
because they have the
legal infrastructure
to enable this risk
allocation that will enable
all sorts of market transactions
to happen which otherwise
wouldn't happen.
But if we imagine
infrastructure like
blockchain-like
infrastructures or Ethereum
infrastructures
to enter the mix,
providing a technical
infrastructure that
doesn't require judges and
lawyers but just requires code,
then that can substitute for
the legal infrastructure,
provide the infrastructure
the contract needs
at a much lower cost,
and thereby enable
people to contract who otherwise
wouldn't rationally contract,
because they could never
count on the infrastructure
of the legal system to
deliver what they need.
OK.
So the point is this
picture is trying
to say that one key value
of these technologies
is that they will be a
substitute for a failed
legal system or a legal system
that's not yet developed.
They will provide
the infrastructure
of a legal system or
the legal systems.
AUDIENCE: How can they
really do anything?
Because you can't make
that contract like,
I will pay you $3.50 per bushel
on September 1 in Ethereum,
because you're making a
statement about the real world.
The Ethereum blockchain
cannot verify that I gave you
the bushels.
LARRY LESSIG: OK.
So I've got two slides to get
to your example [INAUDIBLE]..
OK.
AUDIENCE: There's ways to do
it, but they're very risky,
I should say.
LARRY LESSIG: Right.
But let's bracket it for just--
I'm not sure if it's
two, but it's n slides.
But n is less than
100, I promise.
So just hold one second, OK?
So if you say that
one function here
is to substitute for
a failed legal system,
that suggests that the
other key opportunity here
is to enable contracts where the
transaction costs right now are
otherwise too high.
So this is a key opportunity
to think of places where
if you can lower the transaction
costs of the contract,
you will enable a
contract which otherwise
can't exist right now.
So I'm on a scientific board
for an insurance company.
So I was meeting the
president last week.
And he was all excited
about a new product which
they were investing in,
which was going to provide
flight delay insurance.
And this product was going to
be completely blockchain driven.
And this is what I'm trying
to get to your point.
It would trigger payments in a
completely automatic way based
on the information
that's being reported
from the n different sites
that are reporting information
about flights.
So I buy the contract.
It says, if my flight is
delayed more than an hour,
I get paid $200.
And automatically,
as he put it, it's
a no-touch product,
by which he meant
no human needs to touch this
product for this contract
to be enabled.
It's a kind of
product that never
would have been available
before, because the transaction
costs of engaging it
were way too high.
But now that we've lowered
the transaction cost
and have an infrastructure
of trust, which
is what the blockchain
is providing here,
there's a huge
market that now is
available for a contract
that otherwise just
wasn't there before.
Now, that market depends on
making a couple assumptions.
You're not saying that
there's 100% certainty
that everything in
that market is working
the way it's supposed to work.
But the point is you
don't need 100% certainty
for the vast majority of
these kinds of contracts.
If it gets it wrong
every once in a while,
that's good enough
for government work
or good enough
for airplane work.
And so that's going to
be sufficient to enable
the market, recognizing that
even in the legal system
market, guess what?
It doesn't always
get it right either.
But it doesn't always enforce
the contract well either.
In fact, the costs
are much, much higher
to fail in the legal system.
OK.
So two kinds of
transaction costs.
One system transaction
cost suggests
that where you have less
developed legal systems,
the blockchain is going to
provide a real opportunity,
because you're going to
lower the transaction
costs for those systems.
And the other is just
contract transaction costs.
There'll be a huge
explosion of markets where,
right now, the contract
transaction costs are so high,
and we can lower them
and thereby enable
a certain kind of
transaction that
otherwise wouldn't be there.
OK.
Final point I want to make.
The other thing technologists
always love to say
is the great thing
we will do when
we do contract
technology is they'll
solve the clarity problem.
Every term will be
perfectly clear.
Because you write
those contracts out,
and there's all sorts of
ambiguity and vagueness,
and it's a total mess.
But when we've coded
all of our contracts,
our smart contracts,
then we'll have
perfect certainty for
every single outcome,
and that will be great.
And the point I want
to suggest to you
is that, often, obscurity
is a real value.
Obscurity is what you want,
because here's a way to see it.
So imagine this is
a decision tree.
And it's really
small, because I just
stole it from the internet.
And it doesn't have anything
to do really with what
I'm talking about here.
But imagine a really
complicated decision tree
like this, which is to represent
all the possible things that
could happen with our deal.
So I want to buy the house.
But what happens if the
house gets hit by a meteor?
Or what happens if
you go bankrupt?
All of these possible outcomes.
And in principle, we could
say we should be negotiating
every one of these blue dots.
We should be saying, what
happens if this happens?
OK, then this is what you
get, and this is what I get.
What happens if that happens?
What you get, what I get.
OK.
So imagine this
blue dot here has
a 0.002% chance of happening.
So you know the chance of that
happening is practically zero.
And so what's the
reasonable amount of time
you should spend
negotiating that term?
Zero, right?
Especially because if
this term is something
you know he's really
worked up about
and you could never come to
an agreement about that term,
it would be ridiculous that
the whole contract fall apart
because of this
0.002% possibility.
So what contracts
do all the time
is they create
these fuzzy or vague
or ambiguous places as a gamble.
It's like, OK, we'll go forward.
We're going to just gamble
that this 0.002% outcome won't
happen.
Most of the time, in fact,
you can work out how often
it doesn't happen, right?
So most of the time,
that would be just fine.
And if it turns out to
happen, then what we'll do
is ask somebody--
namely, a judge-- to
figure that term out.
We'll say, what should that
term be interpreted as?
It was ambiguous, so what
should the answer be?
And the judge will look at it.
And judge will say, well, it's
fair that you win or he wins.
So the point is
there are many times
when you ask the
question, should you
negotiate a term ex ante?
And the answer to
that question is no.
And in those
contexts, an ambiguity
is a way to negotiate it ex
post, meaning after the fact,
ex post, by using the court.
So as we think about these
digital smart contracts,
this is why smart contracts are
referred to as dumb contracts.
They're smart contracts
for the equivalent
of dropping a dime
in and getting a Dr.
Pepper, the sorts of things
where the possibilities are
really small and narrow, or,
like my CEO was really excited,
is your plane late?
Yes, I get $50.
No, I don't.
Things where it's
relatively clear.
But there's a really
important conceptual question
about what happens
when we're trying
to use them for the kinds of
contracts where what we want
is ambiguity.
Because if the very terms of
deployment of the platform
demand specifying all of the
outcomes in this tree, then
your basic thing is a
whole bunch of contracts
you're just not going to be
able to have in this space,
because the cost of specifying
that tree will be higher
than the benefit
of those contracts.
So it's a weird sense in
which, on the one hand,
I've said to you that
this technology can
lower the transaction
costs of contracts.
But for this kind
of contract, it
can actually increase the
transaction costs of contract.
Because for this
kind of contract,
if it reveals the ambiguities
we need to negotiate about
and those negotiating
ambiguities are just
too costly for us
to negotiate, then
it's going to block us
from having that contract.
It forces us to see the
0.002%, and you and I
have to come to terms on it.
And we don't yet have a
good way to fake ambiguity.
I mean, the legal
system fakes ambiguity,
because we just say, oh, yeah,
yeah, we didn't see that.
They saw it.
He knew it when they
wrote the contract.
But they don't have
to admit they knew it.
But the code has to admit it
knows there's an ambiguity.
And that's a hard thing to
self consciously prevent.
OK.
So I've given you four ideas.
Happy to take
questions or abuse.
Usually, I get abuse from
business school students,
but OK.
AUDIENCE: So what if you can
code into a contract the easy
scenarios and then say else-if--
LARRY LESSIG: Go to court.
AUDIENCE: --go to court or
some multinational court
that is the Ethereum
court or whatever.
LARRY LESSIG: Yeah.
And even the Ethereum court will
have to have a court above it
if it wants to avoid government
saying, if you have anything
to do with Ethereum, we're
going to punish you, right?
So this is the sense of
which I wanted to suggest,
to go back to your
first question,
that if you think about it as
layers of an onion, peel layers
back enough, and you're
going to, in the end,
have to get to a state
in some sense, a state
as an enforceable mechanism.
And that enforceable
mechanism doesn't
have to be for every case.
Again, 99% of the time,
you drop the dime in,
you get the Dr. Pepper.
But there's a contingency where
you drop the dime in, and out
comes a bottle of gasoline.
And then you need to
go to somebody and say,
you breached this contract.
And that person--
AUDIENCE: But if it's a contract
between somebody in Alaska
and somebody in
Rwanda, you still
have the question of
which state you go to.
What's the jurisdiction?
So I feel like there
would have to be
some extranational extra-state.
LARRY LESSIG: Yeah.
So you will see in
these types of contracts
is there'll be a whole bunch
of boilerplate that specifies
choice of law, which turns out
to be a relatively easy thing
to do right now, choice
of jurisdictions.
For most countries,
it's pretty easy.
There are standard
ways to do that.
All of that will plug
in automatically.
But again, all of those
are outside of the code.
All of those are law.
AUDIENCE: Comment
and a question.
So I don't trust Vatalik
or other software engineers
that they have the legal
understanding and capacity
to write legally
binding contracts.
So I trust the government
or I trust the court.
I don't trust a
software engineer
to write a proper code to
protect me or my counterparty.
So what is your take on
those smart contracts?
PROFESSOR: Can I add to that?
Not only your take on
whether to trust but what
the courts in Europe and the US
right now do if somebody says,
I wrote the contract,
and here's the code.
LARRY LESSIG: Well, so
when you say-- let me just
me understand the
question better.
I'm sorry.
Your name is--
AUDIENCE: Hugo.
LARRY LESSIG: Hugo.
The way Hugo
described it, I think,
is nice, with a whole bunch of
conditional statements, which
is the code.
So the code says,
if the plane leaves
more than 30 minutes late, then
transfer $100 to his account.
So you don't trust
Vatalik's system
to be able to implement
that conditional?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
I don't understand-- I
mean, I don't know the code.
I don't know if it's breakable.
I don't know if Jean can
log in and change it.
LARRY LESSIG: I'm sure she can.
But the point is,
for most people,
this is true of everything.
When I say to you,
I'm a lawyer, I'm
going to write the contract so
you can sell your car to Andy,
you can have the same questions.
You can have the
question whether Andy
is going to have a way to
flip the price so instead
of $10,000, it's 15,000.
So this uncertainty
is everywhere.
It might be Vatalik
would say, actually,
there's a more robust
way to verify my code
than Lessig's contract code.
Because Lessig's contract
code is written in English,
and we have all sorts of--
but my code, you can
have independent people
who verify it.
So at the level of conditionals,
I'm pretty confident.
What I'm not
confident about is--
and I had the great pleasure
in December of 2015 spending
a weekend with them,
watching that group.
And it's this weird kind of--
he is like the messiah
figure, and there's
12 people sitting on the
floor around him listening
to his every bit of wisdom.
So it was inspirational
and scary at the same time,
because you see how
much money is resting
on this messiah's structure.
But I have a lot of
confidence in their ability
to do the conditionals.
But I'm not so
confident that they yet
thought through how it plugs
into the bigger legal story.
And that's part of what I
was trying to pitch to them,
that's what I'm trying--
to him, and that's
what I'm trying
to pitch to you, that it's
never going to be the case.
I was at this conference in
Australia where I met them.
And so many of the people there
were speaking the way people
spoke about the
internet 20 years ago.
It's like, oh, there's
the real world.
We have governments.
But we're going to create--
like John Perry Barlow speak.
We're going to create
this virtual world where
there is no governments,
where we just
live free of government.
And it's so fucking naive
about the way this stuff works,
because it's always embedded
in a real world which
has a real government.
And that real
government is not going
to look the other way if
you're doing lots of damage
or not paying your taxes.
So the question isn't whether.
The question is just
how and how much.
PROFESSOR: Can we go back there?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So I have a question about,
what kind of implications
do you think this technology
has to broaden access
to legal services in general,
like letting people know when
they're being taken advantage
or being able to provide more
standard versions of
really common contracts,
like employment contracts
or lease contacts
and things like that?
Do you think that this is going
to be a game changer for those?
LARRY LESSIG: Absolutely.
I mean, you've got to
muster the political will
to break the monopoly
lawyers have in this space.
And I'll tell you, we're going
to fight hard against it.
But there is no reason
for 90% of what lawyers
do to be done by lawyers.
Just like if you
buy a house and you
have to have a
lawyer who sits there
and basically signs
documents for you.
You're like, why?
And the answer is
because the law
has been written to require that
person to sit there and sign
documents.
And why?
Because the people who
get paid to sign documents
have corrupted the law.
So there's lots to clean up.
But if we can clean
it up, absolutely.
99% of this stuff
ought to be automatic.
And then let's get the lawyers
to focus on the hard corner
cases, not on everything
that should be automatic.
And that certainly
should be true
not just within a jurisdiction
but across jurisdiction.
AUDIENCE: Can I return to
your insurance examples?
I got the idea that you could
write a smart contract that
would pay you automatically
if the plane was late.
But then you said it
puts it on a blockchain.
Can you connect why he put it
on the blockchain as opposed
to just putting it on
his disc and letting
your credit card get credited?
I mean, where did the
blockchain enter into that?
And why did he need
a blockchain in order
to maintain that statement?
LARRY LESSIG: I think that
the thing that he thought
he was getting out
of the blockchain
is to increase the
verifiability of third parties
of the actual payments
according to the data.
So if I say to you, I'm
going to be paying you
$500 if your plane
is an hour late
and we have the data out there
about the planes being late,
if he did it inside of
his insurance company,
I wouldn't have any way
to know that he paid you
$500 for the plane being late.
But if it's in a blockchain,
there's at least conceptually
a way in which we
could be doing this--
not that I'm
reviewing it to you,
but we could be signaling--
AUDIENCE: That doesn't follow.
So that depends on who
maintains the blockchain.
And then at the same
time, it returns that.
Suddenly, everybody
knows the cash flow
of that insurance
company, which is likely
not something he wants to do.
LARRY LESSIG: Well, the cash
flow of the insurance company's
bigger than authenticating
the truth about certain types
of contracts.
AUDIENCE: Well, let
us know the cash flow
of that part of the business.
So I mean, he may not want that.
I may not want everybody to
know what planes I'm flying.
So you've implied
that there's now
a public blockchain that does
that to everyone to verify.
LARRY LESSIG: Yeah.
All I mean to argue--
and I didn't
interrogate him far.
I was just taking his
statement that he's doing.
So I'm trying to think,
why would he want to do it?
Because I had the same kind
of question you wanted to.
And it's just that if you are
trying to create credibility
around your claim--
but do I have a reason to
trust this insurance company
that, in fact, it's
going to be doing this?
Then there's some transparency
that this enables--
not necessarily the transparency
of your credit card number
or your name or the
flights that you're taking,
but that there was somebody who
was on this who had a contract,
and we then made
this kind of payment.
That would be a potential
value that he has.
Now, if there's no value
from that, then you're right.
The overhead of the
blockchain or public
or private or
whatever is too high,
and he just could do it inside.
And for certain
companies, like if you
went to a credible insurance
company, the credible insurance
company, you probably trust
that credible insurance company.
But again, if you're a not
credible insurance company,
if you're a startup and you
are out there in the market
and you're saying,
give me your money
and I'll pay you if
the plane's late,
people are going to say,
why should I trust you?
And you're like, well, here.
You don't really
have to trust me.
Here's the data.
Here's the evidence in a more
credible way than if I just
published a report on
my website that I'm
doing what I say I'm doing.
PROFESSOR: Let's try to--
AUDIENCE: He has
to escrow the $500.
PROFESSOR: Andy, let's try to
get a couple more questions.
But my hunch is that it's
probably a permission rather
than permissionless blockchain.
And it may be the
insurance company
wants to ride on the
buzz of blockchain.
But it's possible,
also, that he thinks
that there'll be more
trust, that consumers
will trust that if it's
called a blockchain.
But you did an interview.
You can pick who you want to--
LARRY LESSIG: Right here.
AUDIENCE: So proof
of performance,
could this whole smart
contract solve it?
So for instance, some
countries will receive--
and I was talking to
Leonardo about it in Cargill,
in his company.
They deliver wheat
to some countries.
And proof of performance
is always delayed.
And hence, it becomes
a private issue.
So could smart contracts
solve something like that?
LARRY LESSIG: Yeah.
If you had an alternative way
to credibly represent a fact--
and again, this is kind of
connected to Andy's point.
Is there an alternative way?
And is this the alternative way?
Then you lower the transaction
cost of that kind of contract,
because I'm going to trust
the contracting process more
if I'm confident that, in fact,
the fact that I'm not late
doesn't penalize
me, or you don't
penalize me claiming I'm late.
So to the extent you lower
the cost of verifying
facts in the world, you
increase the opportunity
for certain contracts to happen
who otherwise wouldn't happen.
And that's the only
trade-off that I'm
trying to emphasize by
emphasizing the transaction
cost part of these contracts.
You had a question here?
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
I was just saying maybe one
of the benefits of applying
blockchain here would be
not for one-off transactions
but for the insurance
company, perhaps,
to have an aggregate
thousands of transactions
where they've shown performance.
And they can use this
for commercial reasons
to show that, yes,
people get paid
when they purchase our
insurance and get credibility
for particular products.
LARRY LESSIG: Yeah.
You would frame that
as it would have
to be that that would be
a value it was providing.
Otherwise, to
Andy's point, there
would be no reason
to adopt this.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Go on the back right.
I don't remember your name
AUDIENCE: Kyle.
So with, I guess, easier access
to these derivative contracts,
do you foresee a
world where there's
a lot more leverage
in any type of market
outside of financial markets?
And do you foresee this creating
kind of a risk in that way?
LARRY LESSIG: Well, I mean,
this is your expertise, right?
Because, I mean, we already
saw in the derivatives market
the fact that the
choice by policymakers
was to allow it to be
an invisible market
and not to regulate that market.
It created all sorts of risks
that sensible people might
think shouldn't have been there.
And I think the
same potential is
here, which is, again, to
come back to the point,
don't expect there not
to be government here.
I mean, to the extent
people realize this risk
and don't have as much
political corrupting power
as Wall Street
did in our system,
we should expect
governments [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: I would say yes.
Even on bitcoin, you can create
something called discrete log
contracts to do contracts for
differences or derivatives.
But with smart contracts,
you can put a lot of leverage
into the system.
And transactions
can move quickly.
So I think the state will
have an interest, particularly
if it grows.
We probably only have time
for two more questions.
And I'm still wondering,
how do courts currently look
at these as a matter of law?
In the late 1990s, I
was honored to work
with Senator John McCain
on something which
became the e-signature law.
I was just playing point for
the US Department of Treasury.
It was really John McCain's
law Congress was doing.
But I'm wondering
how the courts today
would see these contracts.
Do we need something
like an e-signature law
to have code accepted beyond
what e-signature accepted?
LARRY LESSIG: No.
I think the e-signature
infrastructure
is going to be 99% of
what this system is.
PROFESSOR: You mean that which
I worked on 20 years ago?
LARRY LESSIG: Yeah.
You solved 99% of the problem.
PROFESSOR: Little did I know.
LARRY LESSIG: Here, too.
Yeah.
I mean, that's why I
wanted to wrap this
around the idea of a
soda pop machine, right?
So it's nothing
new, in some sense.
Contract law has always
dealt with machines that
are delivering on obligations.
It's just a more
sophisticated set
of proofs you're going to
have to make in a court.
But it's the same
underlying plot.
PROFESSOR: One more question.
We're MIT.
We're supposed to end
five minutes early.
LARRY LESSIG: Oh, OK.
PROFESSOR: I don't know
what you do at Harvard.
LARRY LESSIG: I don't remember.
PROFESSOR: It's Harvard Law.
LARRY LESSIG: Right here.
AUDIENCE: So I have a little
bit of the opposite question
from Elon, which is a lot of the
contracts you're talking about,
simple contracts, right?
You've got individuals
on one side.
You've got large companies,
like your insurance company,
on the other.
The insurance company
can't, in fact,
go through the
entire decision tree
and decide what every
term is in their favor.
And the law deals with
that all the time.
But here, you have another
problem, which is now,
it's going to be OK.
It's going to be written
in computer code.
How are the judges
going to deal with that?
Now it's a language
that is going
to be even tougher to
deal with that problem.
LARRY LESSIG: Great question.
And the answer is--
so this is actually another
version of your question.
The answer to that is
nobody knows right now.
And so this issue gets raised
in a lot of parallel contexts.
For example, there's a Supreme
Court Justice from California
who's doing a lot of work about
the question of black boxes
that predict whether you are
likely to commit a crime again.
So if you're convicted
of crime, the question
is whether you're
going to have parole.
The parole process is supposed
to decide your likelihood
of committing a crime.
So these companies have
built these black boxes where
you spit in every bit of data.
And it comes out and says
yes, you're a criminal,
or no, you're not.
And then the lawyers
come forward,
and they say, well, I want
to interrogate the black box.
I want to know what--
And the courts are completely
confused about this.
Because on the one
hand, they say,
no, no, this is
their trade secret.
But on the other hand,
they're like, wait a minute.
You can't decide whether
I have liberty or not
based on these black boxes that
just spit out numbers, right?
So I've got to be able
to interrogate them.
Right.
So this is the most
important innovation that's
got to happen in the law.
Lawyers have to
become technically
sophisticated to be
able to read code
like they read legal contracts.
They have to have a conceptual
understanding of what
code can do so they can
think creatively about code
like they think creatively
about language, right?
And one of the most
important innovations
that we, like the Berkman
Center and people like that,
are trying to push into
the legal environment
is to insist that just
like lawyers now all study
economics, because that's a core
way of thinking about the law,
we also should study
basic code so we
can think about this
modality of regulation.
Not expect people are
going to be writing code,
but at least that they
can think through it.
So I completely agree.
That's a fudge space that
I didn't talk about at all.
But I think it's a really
important problem, thinking
about whether the
legal system is going
to be able to deal with it.
Because if none of the
lawyers understand it, yeah.
Let me just end with
one story about that.
So when I first started
doing this work, talking
about code and--
I went to Paris 20 years
ago, and I gave a speech
to some lawyer group.
And I sat down after the speech.
And the chairman of this legal
group sat down next to me.
And I introduced myself.
And he stood up, and
he grabbed my card.
And he crushed it.
And he threw it to the ground.
And he said, I am
not a technician.
And his point was
he, as a lawyer,
could never accept the idea that
what he needed to understand
was code.
That was forbidden.
It was beneath him.
And I think it's a hugely
important cultural problem
to integrate this
form of knowledge.
Because if we don't, then the
problem you're talking about
is really a huge problem.
But I think we can, because
we've seen lots of--
PROFESSOR: So I
want to thank you
on behalf of the class,
Blockchain and Money.
[APPLAUSE]
I also want to say you're much
better than Christopher Lloyd.
And if anybody wants
to know the joke,
watch that West Wing episode
that Christopher Lloyd plays
Professor Lawrence Lessig.
So thank you.
See you on Thursday.